[موسيقى]
فتاح به تفتتح القائمه قائمه صواريخ ايران
البالستيه التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت
عنه هو صاروخ من انتاج مركز الصناعه
الجويه التابع له وليس اي صاروخ
فتاح صاروخ بعيد المدى محركه يعمل بالوقود
الصلب وهو قادر على تغيير مسار حركته بعد
الانطلاق بسهوله تامه
وقادر على اصابه الاهداف على بعد
1400 كيلومتر كما ان مما يميزه قدرته على
تجاوز اكثر انظمه الدفاع الصاروخي تطوره
تزوجت هنا تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي مع
تكنولوجيا صناعه الاجهزه والاجزاء الحساسه
والدقيقه
انها ثمره لجهود محليه خالصه يقول
الايرانيون ويقول رئيسهم المزيد
الصناعه الدفاعيه والصاروخيه الايرانيه
اصبحت محليه وليست مستورده ولا يمكن
ايقافها عبر التهديدات اليوم تمكنا من
الوصول الى قوه رادعه في الصناعه الدفاعيه
وهي نتيجه جهود قواتنا المسلحه وصناعه
الدفاعيه الايرانيه وستكون مصدر امن
واستقرار وسلام مستدام لدول المنطقه القوه
الصاروخيه والدفاعيه التابعه للقوات
المسلحه تمنع اعداء ايران من ان يفكروا
بالهجوم على بلادنا
تضع طهران المساله في نطاق تحقيق الرضع في
الصناعه الدفاعيه ولا يبدو ان جهود
الخبراء الايرانيين قد نالت منها العقوبات
الغربيه المتلاحقه على طهران
فالخزانه الامريكيه فرضت لتوهه عقوبات
جديده على افراد وكيانات في ايران والصين
لدعمهم البرنامج الصاروخيه الايراني ذاك
البرنامج الذي طالما دفعت واشنطن باتجاه
اقحامه في اي اتفاق جديد للقوى الكبرى مع
طهران لكن بالرغم من المعارضه الامريكيه
والقلق الاوروبي ينقل الايرانيون صناعه
الصواريخ الباليستيه الى ابعاد جديده
وتجدهم في الوقت عينه حريصين على بيان ان
البرنامج دفاعي بحت وغايته الرضع
كبار المتوجسين يقاربون المساله بشكل اخر
اسرائيل مثلا ترى مصلحتها في منع ايران من
حيازه قدره النوويه عسكريه وترى المصلحه
متعديه منطقا ووجوبا الى قدرات ايران
الصاروخيه التي نمت بشكل لافت في الاعوام
الاخيره انه موسم الوعيد في اسرائيل يقول
وزير الدفاع هناك
ردا اقوى على كل سلاح يتباهم يصفهم
بالاعداء بتطويره الرد بحسب يمكن ان يكون
جوا وبرا وبحرا وبالوسائل الدفاعيه
والهجوميه